this is not the weather at [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] what have we done the past week
into a racetrack yes a week we stopped
in Regina
yeah we're China that's a real city name
and such as it's pronounced Regina it's
not Regina it's funny because I growing
up like Regina was a place that I'd go
all the time for diving meet so I
thought it was funny when I was like
eight uh-huh
you know Regina then you get over it and
it just becomes a city that's close to
relatively close to Calgary yeah
relatively close to vagina you know but
you tell anyone that hasn't heard of
Regina before that we stopped in Regina
they're like you stopped where Regina
are you serious well yeah I like rhymes
with vagina
yeah no no [ __ ] it's [ __ ] absurd and
it is kind of absurd I do I do feel for
those people yeah I don't I want to know
who called it that who's [ __ ]
responsible for Regina one big troll man
I think I think we should call it
Clayton Ville now what about Regina yeah
okay I guess these phones [ __ ] with
the signal and [ __ ] yeah so big shout
out to Alina she because it was so is
that we were there on the 18th and my
birthday was the next day and we had a
show and I was like man I never thought
I'd be celebrating 16 in Regina mm-hmm
pretty much it was pretty much that was
like the one day we could do anything
and the boys played the long con they
all Alina and boys got together played a
little prank on me mm-hmm cuz we were
supposed to go eat and then which is
really funny because the way Matt set it
up and everything I should have known
something was up when Matt texts me he
goes yo are you almost ready
I'm like yeah he's like can I come to
your room like is something wrong he's
like no I just want to chill with my boy
well it was like why did he do that I'm
like what's going on here why did he do
that I don't know because that it wasn't
even that is not even like beneficial to
the plan at all no because it we
executed it flawlessly hidden David do
that yeah
I don't know so what would happen when
he came to your room he just sat there
and was just chilling
I was finishing getting ready I just
didn't pay any it I don't pay any
attention to it only whatever okay but
that was like mmm and then everyone was
weirdly dressed and ready to go and
lobby and I was like what's the surprise
yeah but you thought we were like going
out to eat right definitely okay yeah
yeah so we're gonna have to eat we all
climb in this taxi taxi just starts
going I'm not really paying attention I
look up and I like it went from
buildings I like look down I look up and
I just see like fields and like gas
mines and [ __ ] I'm we're on a gravel
road yeah I'm like coal factories and
stuff and like and then I just go Matt
where the [ __ ] are we going because ah
sorry man it was the only place with
five stars okay so then you thought oh
cool so I'm like you know
off-the-beaten-path Michelin star
restaurant I'm thinking like I I didn't
even know what to think of my oh [ __ ]
maybe it's like a [ __ ] barbecue place
maybe something really cool and we get
around this Bend and I see like a
racetrack and I go oh [ __ ] let's go
there and Matt's like that's where we're
going and the tax he starts pulling up
to it and I'm like huh he's like yeah
happy birthday dude I'm like what and
Tom's like yo your girl playing this
whole thing brother I was like ha ha I
felt like a kid in a candy store and it
was sick yeah then we we hop out and
it's just like this Kings Park Speedway
and it was just a simple little oval
track with a bunch of local dudes
building cars and racing them and I was
like this is the best [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
it was [ __ ] sick we got there we went
straight to the Cession concession stand
we got like three poutines two orders of
these deep-fried rib things with little
rib balls you know you little balls a
rib yeah short rib balls it and then we
got hot dogs
nothing better than a race track dog
I'll tell you that onion rings onion
right and we just [ __ ] it all up right
while we're watching these cars go
around the track it was crazy
yeah so loud - oh it was so [ __ ] loud
SuperLab what made it tight was just
like how one just how [ __ ] reckless it
was it was borderline demolition derby
it was sick yeah I was sick sick I just
wish they would just keep going you know
I think that's the that's the only part
all those cars just need like five more
grand mm-hmm cuz that's the thing like
they keep running them too hard yeah so
many cars like overheat or like [ __ ]
some valve would break or whatever they
ugh but because it's super [ __ ]
high-energy they don't there's no time
between races like once the cars exit
the next ones come out like in a split
second and they start going so if there
wasn't any issues like like in one of
the races one of the cars you started
[ __ ] smoking like just burning oil
and just smoking and so they stopped the
whole [ __ ] race yeah they like clean
the oil off the off the witch I get
safety concerns right but it'll be sick
if there it is like I just keep going
yeah cars are spinning out all of a
sudden there's like obstacles on the
course and you can't hit the other cars
I mean dude that's basically that's kind
of what happened cuz like it was like an
invitational so they had like random
people showing up yeah this guy brings
like his [ __ ] [ __ ] beater car which
all due respect I mean the carro is good
for it it's meant for his car he used
for dirt racing like exclusively dirt so
like you didn't have like it wasn't like
setup or built for like a track so this
guy take it out there I have no idea man
I have no [ __ ] clue so this guy is on
the track and he's just like his car
can't keep up like it is a steaming pile
of [ __ ] and everyone is like lapping it
like hard and they're like just really
trying not to hit it like he was [ __ ]
up the whole race oh yeah yes the first
and the second guy are neck-and-neck
yeah and they keep the second guy keeps
trying to like take them on the inside
and then like four laps of that and then
all of a sudden this purple car right no
I got [ __ ] they go around them and
it's like resets it's so funny and
they're like
the poll cards like just get the [ __ ]
off the road shut up Chris or batard
over this whoa he just shouted he's like
get this [ __ ] car out of here uh so
funny blessed that purple cars heart man
yeah blessed he had a big heart he did
to go out there yeah you know that takes
him cojones it does bro I was dying to
heaven it didn't [ __ ] Mustang so
there's like there's a specific Mustang
throughout the day he can't keep up his
cars not fast enough and it didn't seem
like he could get traction or like his
suspension like he had crazy like like
understeer like he just kept going off
the track yeah like he had multiple
occasions where he just flew off the
track and then can't pop back on and so
the best part was you [ __ ] slides off
the track and I'm thinking oh he's not
gonna come back
mm-hmm he comes pulling back out onto
the [ __ ] turn at like five miles an
hour and that [ __ ] beautiful blue and
white like old-school Pontiac just comes
around the car I'm like oh you stupid
and he just [ __ ] goes horizontally to
everyone coming at his ass and he just
this beautiful ass car just clips in the
dude like is on the track I'm like what
is it gonna take for you to realize you
gotta go man you have to go and then
eventually they kicked his ass out but
what some of the races like when they
were to hit and each other to the
announcers like a little contact it's
fine
is so funny it's fine they announce her
new less about racing than we did not
already sure you know he used to drive
no way I don't tell me that at all dude
yeah he was saying the stupidest [ __ ]
yeah that's gonna leave a mark
that's all you have to say about what
just happened like six cars are piled up
on the thing but six cars are like the
[ __ ] drifting around the corners and
I think he's just over it you know
saying like he's past the point of like
wanting to be technical yeah
he doesn't care to explain what's going
on
oh man is gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up mm-hmm
that's all people want to hear anyways
check oh [ __ ] well that sucks
it's like yeah I mean it does that's a
formula one's doing wrong there's too
much prestige [ __ ] alcoholic yeah
yeah oh man one of them one of them
[ __ ] french guys crashed into the
Italian dude these cars as fast as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then we got this oh and then after
we got to go and talk with the guy they
open up the pit after all the races are
done you get to go I talked with the
owners of the cars and check them out up
close like I say load them into the
trailers and stuff like that yeah which
was pretty interesting yeah we're gonna
like see the cars up close they're all
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] - the orange one
that number 11 car that thing was nice
it was nice but like nice for a piece of
[ __ ] oh yeah you know I could still fall
totally [ __ ] up from racing so much
and it's it's just a frame with a fast
engine in it and that's all it is
yeah but the chassis was like old-school
I think it was like a like a Dodge or
some was tight
that was only car that look like it was
maintained yeah the rest of them yeah
beat the [ __ ] up garbage but we had a
funny little moment which we don't want
to spoil but uh yeah we can't talk about
it yeah yeah just chatting with the
owners of the cars what's so funny [ __ ]
happened honest a lot of funny should
happen yeah that the best part was a the
one of these young kids he's been racing
there for a minute he was like twenty
two even racing since he was like 16
we're like I don't like posted up on
this car or whatever and he's like he's
like I'll check out the hole in the oil
pan and I like kind of like bend down
and look and there's a fat [ __ ]
and I was like oh [ __ ] what happened did
you know where it was I did but I would
like I know where the [ __ ] oil pan is
at but I won't know oh it's just like
saying the oil pan and I'm like I'm like
looking at the windshield the oil pan
yeah I know what you're saying I don't
know where the [ __ ] it is in the
rearview mirror I don't know the oil pan
in the back seat you guys oil pan yeah
oil pan I'm seeing oil pen
like a weed pen now the oil pan dumbass
it was um
no just sits right below the motor
mm-hmm right yeah yeah it pumps it in
yeah yeah right beside the defibrillator
yeah the food yeah next to the physician
yeah thanks to the rotor belt yeah yeah
yeah and the snaky yeah yeah in the
Bucktown bowl no there's a fat [ __ ] I
like I like bent down and he was like
now the oil pan out I didn't say
anything I want to be like [ __ ] I don't
want to get on my hands and knees like
look under the tire to look at the oil
pan yeah like just like kind of looking
through the top I'm like I can't spot
the hole but I'm sure it's there yeah I
don't need to see the hole that near the
story yeah that yeah that was another
that was another part we were we were
very out of place we're gonna write
about this for sure but because it was
like just such a funny scenario but yeah
we just look like [ __ ] [ __ ] in
that place dude I'm wearing two [ __ ]
just like just sneaker heads stupid la
[ __ ] so [ __ ] out of place everybody
knew we were not from around and they're
like climb in the car like I can't my
jeans are too [ __ ] time I can't get
up into the window yeah that's what I
told the guy that it was like you want
to sit in the car and I was like I don't
know if I'm not my legs can get that
wide did i do want to though it looks
cool would love to get a gram out of
this but yeah so [ __ ] stupid
it was crazy those he was like I was
like what happened like for the whole
he's like oh man the piston just went
and I'd like that like freak me the [ __ ]
out like that's how beat up these motors
are just like the [ __ ] a [ __ ]
piston just disassembles and like shoots
through the bottom of the motor kit like
keep that shoot through this way and
like kill you
that's what happened a hardened Senna
and his like yeah it was like he was
like something suspension related
basically like he went into a turn and
something snapped and it like I think it
like shot through and like perfectly
like nailed his helmet or something like
it was [ __ ] up like Aang yeah
yeah one of the greatest drivers of all
time bro did he die yeah you don't in
like in the crash yeah geez it was
during a a qualifying lap wow that's
crazy had if you if you guys should
watch the art and Senate documentary
it's emotional mm-hmm that guy was a
psycho really yeah
psycho how the psycho for the sport I
think I've talked about this before we
just like his whole like he really was
convinced that like God was with him
when he drove so he drove in a way that
was like you could only drive that way
if you genuine the belief like you were
above mortality yeah and like on average
like this is like a popular quote but on
average his tires were 2 inches closer
in on a turn than every other driver got
you so like his like people would say
like art and when you're just watching
from the stands it literally looked like
his car was like glued to the turn just
because he would push it right up to the
barrier and so what did he drive Formula
One okay but like this was in the days
of Formula one what they were like using
like [ __ ] 8 cylinder motors and it
was like manual like now it's like they
have like the you know paddle paddle
shifting and all these like you know all
these computers like doing the work but
he would be he would like Drive in the
rain but he would drive at the speed and
pace like it was dry I'd be full-on
raining and like he's like a minute
ahead of everyone else cuz everyone's
like you're a [ __ ] nutcase so just
kind of like as a matter of time before
he crashes and some [ __ ] happens I mean
even if he crashed it like it wasn't
that it what happened was I think they
had changed the rules and then I think
he was driving for Renault at the time I
forget
basically they kind of they changed the
setup of the car and I think it was I
don't know I'm starting misquoting stuff
but I wouldn't say it was a matter of
time in terms of like what happened to
him what happened to him was super
unfortunate yeah but and he was the best
driver of all time one of the best
drivers of all time for sure yeah I when
I went and saw NASCAR one time it was
pretty similar to what we saw it at
Regina
yeah but NASCAR's more is interesting
and in terms of like passing yeah I
think there's more there than you would
get out of like
one Formula one is like some tracks
allow for that other tracks not so much
and definitely more like it's it's
easier to just catch the bike - guys
like gone at it out of like a hundred
cars yeah but yeah I mean when did you
go this was in college we took like a
party bus to a NASCAR track and it was
so in Regina there was a section where
you could drink section of the stands
where you could drink was a call like
the beer garden yeah which is no it was
just it's so void of any sort of plant
or anything it was literally just a
fence and then like dry like some grass
yeah that's the beer garden but I
actually like that because it was
literally just a beer garden yeah yeah
yeah little beer little beer plants yeah
beautiful no I know we took a party bus
out there I think I've talked about this
before but it was just yeah it was it
was [ __ ] crazy
it really was people just bring giant
coolers of natty light and just get
[ __ ] up like whole families you know
yeah yeah it's really loud and it was
really no it's really cool but III have
to say the best probably the best joke
of the whole day at the racetrack was
when one of the races ended and Matt
looks us and say he says nice finish
here in Regina in Regina I the best bit
was own words so we leave the racetrack
and talk to all the first off the random
people from Regina who knew who we were
who just pulled up to say what's up
mm-hmm these three kids like pull up
they're like yeah we're going to a party
weren't a huge party and still just
sitting with a gigantic sandwich in his
lap so [ __ ] weird sized sandwich and
they're all Hawaiian shirts yeah you
guys have a beach themed party and
Regina I guess I kind of make sense
they're like yeah yeah yeah and so
whatever we get in this cab and we're
heading to a casino we're talking about
the races and more you know we're all
you know whatever just shooting the [ __ ]
then in the middle of conversation Matt
goes it's crazy because all those
drivers are bisexual too and the cab
driver like his head you know like
drivers usually just stick to the road
yeah his head spun so fast to the right
and like his face was like why do you
how do you know that like you know I'm
saying like he appeared as though he was
tuned out to the entire conversation and
then he heard that just broke character
he's like what just kept double taking
on Matt he's like like he just like
couldn't process why Matt would know
that or why that would be true yeah yeah
every single one of them is it a
requirement to race in this race it just
came out of nowhere is this [ __ ]
[Music]